let's jump into this first story from
ign.com Activision polls FaZe Clan
streamer Nick Merk's skin from Call of
Duty following
anti-lgbtq plus tweet quote we are
focused on celebrating Pride with our
employees and our community so first who
is this guy FaZe I believe I have his
YouTube right here he is a streamer
plays video games he's got 4 million
subscribers and what exactly did he say
that got his skin pulled from this game
he said they should leave little
children alone that's the real issue
leave them kids alone so uh there's a
great and powerful Revelation in this
tweet and what's happening
in response Activision tweeted this a
Call of Duty on Twitter which is an
Activision game Charlie Intel says it
appears Activision has removed the Nick
Merks bundle from the war zone and
Modern Warfare 2 store this evening
Activision has not commented on why it
has been removed but the removal of his
bundle comes a day after nickmark's
recent comments about the LGBT plus
Community Call of Duty says due to
recent events we have removed the Nick
marks operator bundle from the Modern
Warfare 2 and Warzone store we are
focused on celebrating Pride with our
employees and our community
is actually pretty amazing let me get
right to it
Nick Merks did not say anything
anti-lgbtq
he said they should leave little
children alone that's the real issue
let's break this down let's dissect what
this uh prominent streamer with millions
of followers on Twitter and millions on
YouTube said leave kids alone
if a leftist showed up to a school where
they were protesting
uh parents were protesting these books
an antifa person said leave the kids
alone
is that anti or pro-lgbtq it's very
vague if a leftist said leave kids alone
they would assume it was a leftist
statement and say the right is targeting
kids
Nick Nick marks didn't say anything
specific other than leave kids alone it
could have been left or right wing so
there's something else you can see here
the fact that simply by saying leave
kids alone
the left got triggered angry and pulled
him from this game shows they actually
understand that they are targeting
children with something negative well
what is this it's a response what's it
in response to
so this Puckett account says this
happened four blocks from my OverWatch
League apartment Americans are in a sad
place right now let people love who they
love and live your own life and it was
in response to the video of the parents
fighting with uh with far left as
activists you can see the sign here
protect trans kids
he says they should leave the little
children alone that's the real issue now
hold on
why is it that the immediate assumption
was that this was a right wing or
anti-lgbtq post
I mean the sign in the video says
protect trans kids wouldn't his
statement be in agreement with what that
sign says protect the kids yeah they
should leave those kids alone yeah I
mean they've totally exposed themselves
on this right and the funny thing is
the hypocritical thing is this is
supposed to be like the party of choice
and that's really what this battle is
about is that parents want to be able to
have the choice to have their kids opt
out of the pride month educational
program that they have mandated every
child has to go through now a long time
ago uh when I was in school you could
opt in or opt out of sex education now
I'm sure as it relates to heterosexual
uh education I'm sure that's still the
case but apparently in pride month
there's no opt out like these are the
guys of choice right well no they're not
actually this is about compulsion it's
about control and I think it's about
brainwashing the young people in this
country yes I got that I saw a video of
them dancing through the hallways of the
elementary school like the little kids
and they're like a rainbow they were
like dancing through a rainbow portal or
something yeah I saw that I thought
about it when I was six and seven in
like first and second grade and like
what I would have felt going into that
would have been very afraid like not and
I maybe that sounds crude but like I
don't just like I I it would have made
me nervous because I didn't know what it
was and everyone's screaming but like
they wanna it's a chance to not have to
do boring school work so everyone's in
for a lot of people are into it but like
I can see how kids would be like not
comfortable but not saying anything
about it because when you're seven what
the hell can you say and who can you say
it too well and this is just one event
that's happening in the Unified School
District of Los Angeles they've now
instituted I think it's like five
separate days of you know uh trans
awareness and a Day of Silence and
another pride month and this and this
and that if these people celebrated like
the Fourth of July maybe perhaps like
they celebrated this we'd have a very
different country right I mean it's
insane let me let me show you this uh
Nick Merks responded to the backlash
saying friends are created in good times
but families are built through adversity
appreciate all of you that have my back
understand my position as a new father
and recognize the love I have for all
ain't no Hate In This Heart pnl
I mean that's it I mean it's very well
set look back down I have three kids
right and no one is in control of my
kids except me and my wife that's it
they want control over everyone's kids I
mean we've seen that debate happen over
and over again they want to have the
control of shaping our child's uh uh
future yes their thoughts what they're
going how they view the world that's me
I am in control of them I am their
parent not these teachers not these
activists me and my wife the left is
motivated to affect the what they call
cultural hegemony so when you have kids
and you send them to what you assume are
schools that are going to teach them how
to be good Americans how to be liberals
how to be you know uh live in our
society
when you do that you make more
capitalists that's what schools used to
do nowadays the well and what happened
was the left realized that to to break
that reproduction of the society is the
only way that you're gonna get to a
socialist United States so they go into
the schools using a free airing method
and they break that hegemony by teaching
children
their morals and their uh you know moral
the way that they want Society to be
what's the freearian method Palo friario
is a was a uh Portuguese uh Marxist and
he is is the most influential in current
schools
um basically he wants to have generative
issues so the way that he wants to her
the way that his method is teach
children in a way that introduces
political themes to them right so if
you're teaching math
the freyrian method figures out a way to
not only teach the math lesson or teach
the math lesson and additionally teach
the political aspects or teach political
aspects like how many stars are on the
flag how many stripes are on the flag
yeah stuff like that but um so they
would maybe they're talking about uh you
know maybe they're talking about how
much it costs to get into maybe they're
talking about about money right or
talking about you know using using money
as a as a as an example
um they would try to direct the
conversation and this is just an example
this is not like this is not the
directed way but they would you they
would try to say well maybe you're going
to get everyone in the car and go to the
amusement park well there's a bunch of
ways that you can make that political
first of all you could talk about the
car well does everyone get into it
everyone gets in the car but is that
really good for the environment are you
going how many people are going in the
car is it is it bad for the environment
to go to the amusement park who's been
to an amusement park everybody's been
you haven't been to amusement park how
come you haven't been to an amusement
park well you know your parents don't
have the money these are all ways they
you can bring up politics in what is
ostensibly a math or a geography or
whatever lesson and if you can teach
kids if you can bring up politics they
call it a generative issue it can
generate questions that's all the LGBT
stuff is when you have kids in front of
a drag queen kids are going to ask
questions why is that person dressed
like that and then you can start talking
about
LGBT issues exactly it's exactly what it
is that's why it's called group because
it makes it normative yes exactly it
gives it gives politically motivated
people an opportunity to bring up
leftist talking points and leftist
politics well and to that point though
part of this is as human beings we have
what's called observable reality right
so to Phil's point I could say Phil
I'm colorblind but that wall looks green
to me phil'd say well I can see with my
vision that is a gray wall Tim say
that's a gray wall as Society we can say
objectively in reality that's a gray
wall
but my perceived reality it's green so
we're having to accept everyone's
perceived reality
I view you know if somebody says I view
myself as a woman and we're all looking
at that person saying uh no
objective reality says no you're not
observable reality says you're not but
we are now having to upset except their
perceived reality do you know where
that's a problem North Korea
they are controlling what is
objective and observed reality right
they are able to control what is reality
and control language that is where we
are headed on this that's what's
Happening Here
and it starts in the schools
it's all it's all grooming in a variety
of ways but but there is overt targeting
of kids with sexual sexual grooming but
there's also ideological grooming and it
all follows exactly what you said
generative issues I know I know I
explained a lot but just for the sake of
context for anybody who hasn't heard
I'll give you a very simple version
modeling
they say do you want to be a model
modeling is a normal job lots of people
model their famous models the groomers
who who use modeling to groom kids will
say you're a model it's normal everyone
does it then they'll say why don't you
wear this bathing suit then they'll say
why don't you take this piece of
clothing off they're slowly inching you
towards something sexual if you want if
if you want to make the claim that
you're just trying to educate kids it
would not start with books that teach
the kids how to use gay dating apps and
that's what they're doing there's a book
called this is gay for those of you that
don't know a teacher in Illinois gave it
to middle schoolers with it within in
the book there's instructions on how to
use adult anonymous gay hookup apps like
that that that is beyond just the the
intro level grooming like she's out
right now instructing them on these
behaviors well and to your point on the
introduction Target right where you had
this huge protest over Target they're
introducing bathing suits generative
issues right yeah they're introducing
bathing suits where kids can tuck
right and well they were adult bathing
suits yeah adult bathing suits but I
mean it's in a place where a family shop
right and then the kid's gonna say Dad
what's tucking yeah what's talking
they're gonna say what's Pride you know
young kids that that don't you know the
first first time that they're cognizant
and aware and be like Daddy what's Pride
Mommy what's Pride right off the bat the
whole month of June has become a
generative issue and if you don't want
your kids to be exposed to that stuff at
four five right six now you're called a
bigot yes it's unacceptable every all
the schools are doing it yeah it's
unacceptable I think conservatives
moderates anybody who's anti-wolf needs
to sue the schools to get the flags
removed 100 yes and just say there it's
a political flag it is offensive to a
lot of people that's just reality you
should not have offensive things and if
the courts deem that you can have it
then start flying the flag you want to
then so there's that there's an issue in
Massachusetts where kid worship said
there are two genders they told them to
take off can't wear that shirt
sued over it the judge said until the
until we have a resolution you still
can't wear that shirt and my response is
okay well then they shouldn't fly the
pride Flags if saying they're too
generous is offensive to some the pride
flag which appropriates God's covenant
the rainbow should be offensive to
Christians and that's a protected class
as well religious belief therefore it
should all go if you can't have one you
can't have the other and that goes back
to that observable reality of two
genders like when children are born that
gender is not determined at Birth it is
observed thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time